il y a toutes sortes d'améliorations
qui pourraient être apportées, mais Amazon ne
veut pas apporter ces améliorations et rendre
le travail plus confortable. Amazon
veut maintenir ses résultats bas. Je
[Musique]
rentrerais chez moi à 18 heures.  réveil le
matin après avoir été allumé pendant 11 heures et demie
et je prenais littéralement
autant d'ibuprofène que
possible médicalement. Je mettais de la glace sur mon poignet sur
mes épaules
et je dormais ainsi en espérant que
l'inflammation  va diminuer et le temps
pour mon prochain quart de travail et pendant des semaines et
des semaines, c'était comme ça
[Musique]
nous ne sommes pas antisyndicaux mais nous ne sommes pas
neutres non plus, la façon dont Amazon
étouffe en quelque sorte toute discussion sur
la syndicalisation, il y a vraiment une sorte de  le
sentiment que les gens sont coincés, ils doivent
l'accepter, il
n'y a aucune possibilité d'améliorer les choses
et si vous ne l'aimez pas, vous êtes
inutile
[Musique]
au lieu de planifier les gens
de manière appropriée en fonction de leurs
prévisions, ils font venir tout le monde pour
un quart de travail et en haut du quart de travail, ils ont
annoncé qu'ils avaient un VTO disponible,
que vous soyez arrivé en voiture, vous savez à
cinq minutes ou à plus d'une heure,
ils recherchent des personnes qu'ils peuvent
renvoyer chez eux en début de quart de travail  et donc
cela fait porter tous les risques de
cette main-d'œuvre flexible sur les
employés réels. L'employé ne
reçoit aucun salaire s'il prend un
congé volontaire, il ne reçoit rien et Amazon
peut alors maintenir ses coûts aussi minimes
que possible.  Les pratiques d'Amazon peuvent
changer. Nous avons vu qu'ils sont
sensibles aux pressions de l'extérieur.
Lorsque Bernie Sanders a présenté le
projet de loi visant à arrêter Bezos, il a vraiment poussé Bezos à
augmenter le salaire minimum. Je pense
que cela devra être une
approche vraiment ascendante et populaire.  type de campagne pour
pousser cette
[Musique]
vous